لن أكون أبدًا جنديًا ، كولين
باول ، جندي تحول إلى رجل دولة صنع
التاريخ على عدة
جبهات ، أول أمريكي من أصل أفريقي وأصغر
رئيس لهيئة الأركان
المشتركة ولاحقًا أول وزير خارجية أمريكي أفريقي ،
لذلك شعرت دائمًا
بقوة ذلك  يجب أن تحاول حل
النزاعات في هذا العالم من خلال
المفاوضات من خلال الدبلوماسية في
أي وقت يمكننا حل مشكلة بهذه الطريقة
وعدم استخدام القوة
وتحقيق أهدافنا ،
فلندفع من أجل أن نشأ باول في برونكس
نيويورك وهاجر والديه من جامايكا
باعترافه الخاص  لم يكن
طالبًا متميزًا ، لقد كان من الممتع
على مر السنين أن يأتي الناس
إليّ ويقولون حسنًا أيها الجنرال باول إنك
رئيس هيئة الأركان المشتركة
عندما ذهبت ومتى تخرجت
من ويست بوينت
لم يكن بإمكانك الدخول
التحق بكلية مدينة
نيويورك
للجيولوجيا وكان تخصصه ، لكن
الروتك أصبح شغفه باول ازدهر
كطالب وبعد التخرج تفوق
كجندي في الخدمة
إد جولتين في فيتنام قبل
الحصول على زمالة مرموقة للعمل
في مكتب الإدارة والميزانية
خلال عهد نيكسون في
عام 1972.
وعاد باول بعد ذلك إلى قواته
ليصبح جنرالًا
وعاد إلى البيت الأبيض في عام 1987 كمستشار
للأمن القومي للرئيس ريغان
ثم في عام 1989 أصبح الجنرال
هو الضابط الأعلى رتبة في
الجيش الأمريكي عندما عينه الرئيس جورج هو
بوش رئيسًا لهيئة الأركان المشتركة.
سنقوم
بقتله منذ متى وأنت هنا ،
أصبح باول اسمًا مألوفًا خلال
حرب الخليج الأولى ، أصبحت
سياسته في استخدام القوة الساحقة ضد
العراق تُعرف باسم عقيدة powwow التي
أعربت عن
خالص شكري لكل واحد
منكم لكونه
هنا لأشارككم آخر يوم لي بالزي الرسمي بعد
35 عامًا من الحياة المهنية المميزة ،
تقاعد باول من الجيش في عام 1993. بعد
عشر سنوات ، ستكون الولايات المتحدة
شارك في حرب
خليج أخرى ولعب باول دورًا رئيسيًا مرة أخرى
زملائي ،
كل بيان أدلي به اليوم
مدعوم بمصادر قوية ، هذه
ليست تأكيدات
ما نقدمه لك هي حقائق
واستنتاجات تستند إلى معلومات استخباراتية قوية
ثم وزير الخارجية باول  قدم
قضية أمام مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة
بحجة أن العراق يشكل
تهديدًا خطيرًا على العالم لأنه قال إن
لديهم أسلحة دمار شامل
في الشهر التالي ،
بدأ
الغزو الأمريكي ، واستمرت الحرب أكثر من ثماني سنوات ولم تستخدم
أي أسلحة دمار شامل.
يؤسفني ذلك الآن لأن
المعلومات كانت خاطئة
بعد أربع سنوات عندما عاد وزير خارجية الرئيس جورج دبليو
بوش
إلى الحياة الخاصة ،
فقد أمضى سنواته المدنية في تمكين
الشباب من خلال مشروعه
تحالف الوعد بأمريكا ومدرسة كولن باول
للقيادة المدنية والعالمية
نحن  سوف نذهب
لتعليم الأطفال الذين هم في أمس الحاجة إليه
وعندما سمعت قصصهم قلت أنني
حصلت على ge  هذا هو المكان الذي أنتمي إليه أنا في
المنزل مرة أخرى
الجنرال كولن باول قائد
ووطني كرّس حياته
للخدمة